hello and welcome to another exciting
installment of game time I'm so excited
bc III is over but they're still video
games going there are still things to be
excited about that are not III one of
them is a portal stories Mel which we
are playing today we're gonna cave
johnson behaved young so this is a this
is not a video games which has been
released commercially jeremy i'm sorry i
know i'd ride you in here under false
pretenses oh this is a fan-made mod for
portal 2 but it's been given that that
hot steam sort of machine or that like
acceptance like it's weird valve seem to
be pretty okay with people like straight
up like promoting mods and this is not a
paid for one this is free so if you own
portal to you can just download it right
now which is what we've done yeah
interestingly enough you don't need to
have portal 2 installed to play or
really own portal 2 right so it's a
complete standalone community made mod
and like you said it's got that sort of
like sheen on it like it feels you know
like it feels like a community-made game
because it's just sure does being billed
as but it's got a nice layer of a as you
said hot steam do you want me to join me
to give you the rundown uh yeah I so you
played a little bit of this just taking
a look at it I am going in totally blind
here so this is these a 5 chapter game
this is at the end of the first one the
intro to the game ends up but you're
coming out of this I won't say what
happens at the start your sweaters yeah
but it is a reminiscent of half-life 1
and 2 shall we say in chod verdad then
you come out of your your pod here which
you were clearly asleep in for too long
it's a familiar don't worry about the
heights and this is my time to Eastern
European dear speaking at you so at the
start there's like a fake Cave Johnson
dude it was like they straight up like a
guy pretending to be cave John's okay um
how do you know it's a fake Cave Johnson
do they make it like abundantly clear he
says yeah he is he is saying I'm Cave
Johnson oh it's clearly not who does the
voice for Kate Johnson oh I could do
yeah I know you're talking about another
name either so I interested so that's
kinda weird so in a way this game kind
of feels like a really polished what I
played really polished student projects
interesting and getting into it I figure
we shouldn't go too far into this
because then we'll just sort of spoiling
a bunch of action
important cause less little looks dumb
if it gets really hard really fast
that's true but here we have the gone oh
it's like a vintage portal gun are you
oh that's hot yeah because this is this
game like the intro of this game starts
in 1952 yes is what it says so like it's
it seems to have sort of like a weird
like 50s almost like the team fortress
aesthetic like it's not team fortress II
at all but just like that's sort of like
pseudo 50s like acidic to it which was
very much in portal to Israel when they
when you dived into the lower and the
lower test but i guess the difference
between that and dish is that this is
very much i feel bad for speaking over
the sky but honestly the dialogue eNOS
is real hit or miss ya like some of its
sounds pretty great something like lambs
write the report although some doesn't I
feel like one thing about the portal
game is he always felt like mechanically
added with the script that they were
given like a real and I don't know like
a thorough like QA process ranked like
writing QA process as well but anyway I
digress and yeah this game is set very
much liked it starts off with this sort
of the Golden Age of aperture like they
just started their new big science place
and they built this town and kind of
goes into the extended fiction much of
it I think they yeah here we are at the
first puzzle and if there's one thing
you know about valve games it's that
always look towards the light it's like
they're their number one design
philosophies you play any of their like
first-person shooter here we have look
it's like like following coins and Mario
yeah basically and then where is that a
lot oh it's over there I wonder if we
can
your knowledge of a game design has
saved us again now all you have to do a
string to a chair so luxe odd little bit
older than he did you just looking a
little age in their picture very
handsome and I in our room there's yeah
so one thing I was reading about this
game is that they focused on making the
puzzles Very logic-based because you
know clearly there's a lot of like logic
puzzles and previous portal games but
there's definitely a few or it's like
you got to be quick about it it's like
it's it's a finesse puzzle of some sort
right I feel like some of the from what
I played and hasn't been too too much
from what I played you kind of need to
have a working knowledge of the
franchise do it right they introduce
sort of some interesting aspects of the
puzzle design in Portal two rather to
the Ernie in this they don't really
handhold they're not like oh here's how
you shoot a portal and here's how you go
through it and I don't think they do a
wonderful job of trying to like remind
you of how that stuff works in terms of
a real friend edges okay let's just say
that I kind of get that though just
because like you got on portal 2 to play
this and like if you're playing this
you're probably a fan of the portal
series but like I mean surprised to say
it's probably not the best game and for
someone who's never played portal don't
buy portal 2 and then go play this first
if you haven't if you own like honestly
a discount if you don't if you've a
steam account you don't report yet you I
don't know how you've managed to pull
that one yeah have you turned on your
computer in a decade it's a yeah i think
it was like a dollar or two stage there
I want to next time that guy talk to me
we will actually let him talk yeah
because the the cave johnson of the
start it was actually pretty decent Cave
Johnson right yeah this guy i don't know
why i don't know if this guy's
pretending to be downgraded him over
tactic european cave johnson or a weird
if he's the rope if he's a stephen
merchant robot yeah he's from poland i
don't know a sweet little so the tagline
for this gate and this isn't spoilery
because again i haven't played this game
before
another way else ok so we sang like the
husband he's trying to let you know how
you need to get out of here which this
one was used to jump from here ok ok
portal 101 jumping from here like you
want to get out of this building there's
no entrance get momentum right above the
giant exits hot yeah so I was thinking
oh you'll jump down here but none of
this is actual shootable floor portable
so the first time I did this I went into
this room oh ok I would mean time I was
a room at first my god so I didn't
either yeah I wanted to figure it out so
that was some of the complaints and some
of the reviews on this team taylor like
I played for two hours and there are
like rooms I was missing and so I mean
richer turret Oh old-school turret so in
keeping were like trying to figure out
this whole thing then I was like oh
maybe I'll like jump through here and
like I guess remember all the portals
kind of like all the bad like trying
things that yeah in fact if you say
momentum you are entirely right circus
watch this like this and then suddenly
already already we're talking cuz
straight GU first level right goo oh
yeah get that goo sorry I apologize for
my gear oh man alright so you're in the
sliding you you're getting shot this is
this is already way harder than portal 2
got in the first 10 minutes so like this
is why we played this is why we do run
throughs before we do gave her place if
we don't we always go straight in
because this was like a like a whole
process of like okay like it's just
interesting that I gather instantly
involving all that service yeah I kind
of respect that though cuz like it
clearly a lot of this is doing fan
service for all of the portal fans out
there Wow yeah a big portal fat are you
here just personal game design gripe let
me jump over the Oh shame penny was
watching it in the sense in just let me
know aspiring game designers out there
let me jump over [ __ ] which I don't want
to go anywhere as long as it's safe yeah
they probably have lower railings in in
hammer or whatever you make these levels
with its losses i'm at a half-life level
and so yeah here we go look we've got
this little dude i see you get that oil
slick that it makes your business i love
this design actually everything yeah i
like those two they look like the Tommy
gun drum mag on him all right here you
are we didn't need the jumping
and might look different than what
you're used to but while you were
spending that little time sleeping we
had some some Aperture Science
nanomachines come in and build all this
up yeah yeah that's it they're quick
little guys faster than any science guy
I got kind of weird it's like yeah sure
yeah he's got the like the
unprofessional sheen of like an Eastern
European youtuber but you say mrs. dope
fish straight up I don't even know who
that is but yes don't fish lives man
yeah so this was an earth this was an
area you saw earlier right here doing if
you know this is very much of the guise
of um how bout video game yeah so let's
go under well I like already how this is
very like I don't want to say nonlinear
because clearly it's a linear game but
they kind of dump you in more of like an
environment as opposed to like like
original portal I I have played portal 2
since it came out but original portal I
replayed very recently yes and one of
the strengths and weaknesses of that
game is that you're like here's a room
it's a puzzle room and you gotta like
figure out the puzzle room this is like
an environment where you're like in a
dilapidated lab trying to figure things
out which is very portal to but like I
don't know where to go it's like I can
go that way I can go this way over there
that way maybe I should go over here
it's like about and crawl into a ball in
the corners your coach or just play
different game I play Portal to portal
and what ya like it on all this is like
you know it's an open area to explore so
one of the parts when you're coming in
at the start of the game is that they're
saying like oh we are building these ten
different spheres so here the kind of
looks like this one here and we're
building these ten different like
spheres or sphere we can build a all
these fears inside these chambers and
there's like 90 spheres like this all
these different spheres that we can make
that all have their own like test
subjects in them okay they're being
built at the start of the game alright
zoomable you've woken up and perhaps
they have been built already I don't
know Jeremy so impossibly so it's
ambiguous how much time has passed yes
since you like go into the whole tube
thing you came out of completely all
right he's our first test for real oh
god my eyes blinding
go all right Bravo Volta leave hold on
hey testing track yes whoa you'll need a
portal device to get through this just
gets them complying so fast quantum on
the link if I say look it's in your
hands right now the scientists did their
job you'll do fine
of this fake ass porn me too and this
game does have all original music so
props to them for actually having our
original school but it is very cute like
here's some portal music updates go to
me my phone give me some goo give me an
egg view I shoot chocolate through a
portal like that add ups yeah can you
over by the goo platform can you see
anything oh maybe the on that wall along
the to it oh yeah there you go get real
nude it up alright so that's does we got
to glue there
yep
bounce up for your box uh-oh that landed
on your table show really got it before
the answer paid that cube send it home
ok all right real quick you must be
Swift like the coursing lock box oh oh
no oh yikes can mini switches like a box
aux confirm pull switch jump the box
fell oh [ __ ] really this is hard but not
for the right reasons ok let's try it
again all right spawn a box weird the
Box Group Editor how to fall off no
ma'am we got to go to the science tho
except for that whole box falling off ok
all right let's stay there buddy got it
bounced jump o.o is closed held it
nailed it oh yeah oh [ __ ] oh God oh no
it's this an uncontrolled situation stay
there ok so now where does this box go
is the real question here
okay there's a switch there we haven't
gotten on this part you know yeah I
think we've done that [ __ ] yeah let's
stick this down here so it's not I'm
damn it all right straight orange homie
good thing you have those boots that
allow you to not receive injuries
shatter your wrist go your ankles are
really just the wrists of the leg oh you
got this Oh back up yeah yeah music back
that ass up all right let's see we got a
button fun no oh my anus yeah you gotta
bring that box through now oh it's like
straight up on okay I think you just
like toggled it yeah you take off
box-boy
whoa how much if I dropped it right
there I would walk off the set walk
through the grid we would finish this
game stop plays alone it'd just be
gamespot play all right oh god I don't
know my brain is already exhausted you
can walk through this where we can't
take the box right see you can back
master is the other GU speeding you is
there evidence because of the clean
goose so that's a darn you er yeah again
dude I'm here what about this oh oh you
know what I don't move that box before I
do this of a feeling that's what's gonna
happen here that's going to plague you
everywhere think I figured this out I
think I'm gonna bounce across that thing
with you know right oh god this is gonna
be a nightmare and in tears oh no what
kind is that killer are you gonna shoot
it from here though hey yeah I'm all
just doing straight up here has a new
okay so you're nice and good so now you
have to go but you're gonna have to
you've gotta like shoot out of there
like the goo is well i think i'm gonna
have something you gotta like pit drop
over there but you and you have to get
the Box first I know what to do and
that's out there that's our boy okay
orange oh and then you got a blue down
there at boxing relieve ourselves wrong
yeah then go for a wild ride oh my mrs.
Z not gonna work or it's not super
science oh [ __ ] take your time okay can
we get through here without hitting it
oh you got it all right all right take
two for science again oh oh my god did
it all right that was that was actually
awesome little stories mail you got me
back all right awesome nice you know
what Jeremy let's leave it there on a
good note you did it I like to end on a
good note and not as many minutes later
notes took way longer than the edit will
show yep what we did it took no time at
all let's pour these stories logic
masters portal stories Mel and now feel
free if you're already all portal 2 if
you don't hold portal to [ __ ] in this I
maybe go play toppers honey yeah he's
tickle project Applejack it seems like
it's a little bit rough around the edges
but uh yeah I love that first puzzle was
once oh yeah especially if your friends
yeah if that's one gering for some
challenge go play portal to brush up
come back to this in a while get a cup
of coffee and check out portal so i'll
see you next
you